mon pire baume responsable des réseaux
sociaux dinars le but du jeu sur les
réseaux sociaux de li na c'est d'essayer
de parler à un maximum de gens on a deux
axes pour faire ça le premier s'est
éclairé l'actualité avec les archives du
passé donc en fait c'est on va utiliser
les archives pour essayer de donner un
point de vue sur l'actualité pour
essayer de mettre l'actualité en
perspective c'est aussi un travail qui
est fait sur le site ina.fr et puis
ensuite on va essayer d'aller rechercher
est ce qu'on appelle la pépite ça va
être quelque chose qui va être
déconnecté de l'actualité mais qui vont
permettre tout simplement de faire
plaisir aux gens quoi de les divertir
c'est la tour eiffel rendu à la vie
civile dernièrement qui elle aussi à
l'est pas ce travail de vos réseaux
sociaux c'est un travail de psychologie
sociale
comment est ce qu'on va faire pour
toucher les gens comment est ce qu'on va
pouvoir leur crée une émotion que cette
émotion entraîne une interaction
c'est-à-dire un commentaire un partage
ou un like à partir mans où il y aura un
engagement avec le contenu il va y avoir
une viralité sur les réseaux sociaux ont
dit qu on this king le contenu est roi
et le contenu c'est les documentalistes
souvent qu'ils trouvent donc nous on
peut faire des très bons postes facebook
et des très bons trucs et avoir des
bonnes stratégies à la fin le succès
qu'on a c'est grâce à la qualité du
fonds nina et c'est grâce à la qualité
du travail de recherche des
documentalistes ina sur les réseaux
sociaux rempli son rôle de média
patrimoniale puisque on travaille à
essayer de montrer la variété de la
richesse de la culture française ça
passe par le patrimoine musical par le
patrimoine cinématographique par le
patrimoine littéraire puis aussi par le
patrimoine sociétales sociales une
société un état une nation alors ces
trois trucs différents mais parlons de
la nation une nation c'est aussi des
gens qui ont un vécu commun et qui ont
une histoire commune qui ont des
références sociales des habitus sociaux
communs et donc bah quand nous on va
s'intéresser à comment les violences
conjugales étaient montrées à la
télévision dans les années 70 comment
est ce que je sais pas on a fait
tellement de choses sur récemment sur la
bisexualité ou dans les années 80 on a
été tendre des micros à des gens qui
était bisexuel ou sur l'homosexualité
pour moi c'est aussi du patrimoine ça
parce que c'est aussi montrer comment
était la société française comment elle
fonctionnait voilà encore on est
patrimonial
[Musique]